thank you
[Music]
a ground crew worker died after being
ingested into the engine of a plane in
Alabama yo what is it I just got sucked
in one of those [__] spiral things
underneath the wings like Indiana Jones
oh my oh [__] God damn they just Blended
him yeah
yeah and they turned it on and I was
like and just sucked them out what
happened
so the dude was um
yeah so so well damn there's a lot so
the plane was parked one of its engines
was running the airline ground crew
worker was pulled into the engine while
it was parked at the gate with it was he
doing this
yeah so so the so Joe if you think I
know enough about it like that you've
never done this job okay
I actually have
wait what'd you do I was hosting but
they said I wasn't good so I can't be it
anymore who said that a lot of people
it's like the fans yeah yeah
the fans didn't care Bart was like Joe
we're gonna go with a different
direction
put him back in the seat
2023 the attitude here you never did in
the Attitude Era that's true yeah dude
words accept it we'll we'll support you
that is good in the attitude I just hire
people that are better than me at the
craft well that's a good way around
business can't argue with that yeah hey
if you're sitting here and we come at
you with a folding chair in the back
you'll sell that you'll sell a hit right
like ah you son of a [__]
you gotta turn away yeah he couldn't get
me with the the Jiu Jitsu nonsense but a
stunner will [__] me
so the work I've been hit by a chair
before really I me and Bart both oh yeah
at the pro wrestling show
so I don't think I got hit I think I
just watched Barton if I felt the pain I
see it hurts pretty bad though yeah he
whacks you pretty hard you don't do this
with your hands and then go like sell it
we didn't learn it that way we learned
that he we just we're on I'm like doggy
style and he [__] smashed it on the
back oh [__] he's just getting off on it
oh I liked it he's got these two little
Asians
these naughty Asian boy I love Joe Rogan
I do he's great but I'll never forget
him [__] all over wrestling for
years and he has Undertaker on
what did he used to say that [__] on
wrestling well he's just like making fun
of it which by the way a comedian should
it's hilarious but like but then when
taker's on I was like damn he's not
gonna really he should have threw a
little bit of a fun funny fun like fun
yeah a little jab no fun little jab that
Undertaker sells yeah okay so the worker
got um sucked in yeah like I said
parking brake yeah yeah American
Airlines playing all right by the way
they don't let you refund tickets oh
just so you know little tip tool tray so
the
the worker got pulled in They Don't
Really describe it very much except that
he felt like Superman for a second
that's what it says shut the [__]
because right before he got sucked in he
was like I could be like
they got a quote at that exact moment
right because they're like oh my oh
Superman
but you can replace the engine I guess
you know you blow up like like in the
movies like in the or in the footage of
eagles and [__] going into it oh [__]
I'm surprised more birds don't give like
I think they go very fragile they they
like doves and [__] they go through it
and then they spit it on a backwards
yeah because they're small enough to oh
did they just pass by it like real quick
like bald eagles though they really
think it takes a minute the amount of
bald eagles that die by engine turbine
wild yeah like if you were to hold up
like a salad bowl you'd catch pure chili
like bald eagles
so pull the other side it's illegal to
eat bald eagle children
it'd be like slap chopped bald eagle
it's an illegal Eagle yeah yeah you
can't evil
man you're riding low dude
it's illegal because I was like where is
it
so American Airlines confirmed the death
of the employee in a statement saying
they were devastated and they're focused
on ensuring all involved had the support
they need during this difficult time
good man it just sucks to have to
confirm a death like that I wonder what
the insurance policy on that is like the
worst way to go oh man I mean like
American uh American Airlines any
airlines probably has crazy insurance
policies they probably have a better
insurance policy because they don't
refund you if you have to change your
flight so it's probably you break it you
buy it to the guy that got sucked in and
I would know because you know yeah we
didn't read the call sheet and yeah I
didn't really read the schedule this
this month so I booked uh the sixth and
the eighth through the eighth but we
were actually supposed to be here the
next day so then I had to rebook my [__]
and then like you have American Airlines
so you can't you have to pay a fee with
that [__] so it's 90 it's like a whole
new ticket yes it was because I'm coming
from Vegas who gives a [__] 85
I didn't know you were born like that I
I thought you would be doing spirit
because that's what I booked I did
Frontier dude that's cheap too I had to
work the plane I was getting died
can I keep the cat I'm like no you can't
keep the [__] Camp Jesus Christ
[__] Frontier piece of [__] don't
work the place
if you want to hit your ride you got to
work you gotta work to play yeah dude
you can't run out of the shotgun dude
the other guy I was like Luna he's like
Luna
is David we'll be back he's like
whatever and I was like no we will he's
like whatever
there'll be plenty of different people
who got whacked by different coins
joined different companies it's like
Bitcoin dudes go McDonald's
ethereum goes to Carl's Jr let's be real
Bitcoin guys it'll be fine where do the
FTX guys go
to hell dude
they go to Southwest right now I saw it
coming
what about us uh Solana guys huh
[Laughter]
I used to be jealous actually of Solana
like I remember during the run like I
was like man I missed Solana it's crazy
because I remember reading about Solana
I was like they had no killer that's
[__] away how did they just pump so
hard but yeah it's corporate backed and
I and I knew it right when I bought it
went all the way back down David came up
on Solana pretty well did he sell it I
don't know I think he rolled it in into
Luna he did better with Luna we all did
better we all did better we all did
better for a minute with Luna yeah well
we got sucked into the we got sucked
into the great plane engine in a way
explain yourself
for a second for a second you know you
know it's because none of us wanted to
say I'm gonna be the Lone Wolf here and
cash out
we're telling you multiple times I told
you to do it I told
you in front of him he said live on air
that you never told them you never told
me
how many times bark do you think every
time
did I tell this [__] guy to sell
every time I I said I was gonna cash out
Steve was like I think you should be
fighting I think you should I think you
got to make more it's gonna just joke
stop it's gonna be so much more money
you gotta wait wait there's no way I
said [__] blow up you're gonna
[__] do it because it's too early
it's too early wait you know what you're
probably talking about when it was five
bucks
you remember how many times I told this
[__] guy Steve telling Joe and I also
remember Joe saying he was going to cash
out at a million but it went to a
million and he was like nah exactly
thank you well my idea of Cashing Out
was putting it into a stable coin yeah
which was USD
ouchies so that's a maximum algae
situation that was a cash out is that
that was an oofy doofy kind of right
times two that was a big one yeah I did
though because that's how I got away
with 150k
I think the bad thoughts go away this
thing what are you talking about when
you whenever you've been doing that
lately you have a nice like you have a
nice Panic thing you have a joke because
I've been in a high level stress yeah
she's just grinding your teeth not
everybody's a pretty stressor you have a
joke we made no money off of Luna you
see
didn't work out I don't care I just had
fun
yeah baby but at the same time it would
have been much more fun if we kept the
goddamn thing but it still was we got a
little bit the multiple look the
multiples we got sick what those we
could have had
Superman for a second yeah and it's
always worth it to be Superman for a
second damn that's what they got from
his quote some people never get to feel
like Superman nope yeah and live to tell
the tale I just want price to pay you
just get slap chopped it's not bad yeah
imagine it's not quick okay let's um
you're being Blended from leg all the
way to neck and you feel all of it until
you're going a leg from leg all the way
to naked going
you say from leg to leg like you're
doing the splits leg to neck
like this way
[Laughter]
[Music]
laughs
foreign
[Music]